à à
Xin chào các bạn ạ
sự với gì cả
không có tâm sự gì đây cả À
ở nhà mà hôm nay thứ Bảy nó sẽ sự thoải
mái thư giãn nó các bạn ạ
bạn cư chia sẻ tâm sự nhé Hôm nay sẽ một
buổi nó tương đối nhẹ nhàng mình nghĩ
thế
ừ
giờ này 8 giờ nhưng có vẻ vẫn chưa có
người on mấy nhỉ à
à à
ừ hôm nay nhiều lúc tôi thế thôi on may
xuyên đúng vào kiểu
ở chỗ do bóng đá hay gì đó là kiểu xem
cũng kiểu bị ít đi
bà cũng có thể là do mình dậy thường
xuyên quá nên thành ra là
ở Châu Á Châu tặng ở kiểu
Tôi nghĩ tôi nghĩa là mức độ khó nó Nó
đang bị nhiều rồi
anh
em mình cân nhắc là một tuần thì dậy mỗi
ba năm rồi nhỉ
ừ ừ
nghe thuat chấm đỏ bán đi
À hôm nay tôi cũng chưa có thời gian để
chấm đồ ăn với ông từ hôm nay sẽ là
chuyên khoa chấm đồ án đi ạ Thế thôi Tắt
mẹ
Ờ Ờ để tôi sửa lại cái tựa đề phát
ừ ừ
Buổi chấm thì nó sẽ là ờ ờ
ở chỗ ai ai ai xem cũng được thoải mái
và hoàn toàn các bạn có thể ở cổ
an toàn thể châu Á
để xem và Copy tâm sự chia sẻ cho bộ hôm
nay nó thoải mái hơn
em cũng đi
ảnh Tôi đã sửa lại tiêu đề hôm nay sẽ
một buổi chậm đồ ăn đi top
ở lại các bạn ở trong nhóm đồ ăn à
ừ ừ
thì đầu tiên thì tôi sẽ mở cái lên cố
trách xong rồi Tại hết cốt mới về
khi dùng này có sẵn kẹp khi nó sẵn của
tôi cân t thể kéo toàn bộ code mới về
ờ ờ
e27
à à
này
người tôi sẽ xem à
vì vậy
cốt người ông về nó bao gồm cả chưa chưa
chạy được
từ nhỏ ông đã là Facebook như thế này
rồi
Ừ thì tôi sẽ phải chạy Ven Đô từng cái
để mà chạy không nhưng mà chắc là tôi sẽ
Ừ tôi không chấm
tôi không chấm chạy thử mà tôi sẽ chấm
có cốt 2 cái gì đó sau tôi sẽ hướng dẫn
mấy ông về cái vụ là sẽ có một buổi sẽ
có một buổi hơi sẽ ở
chị sẽ hướng dẫn mấy ông này việc là đầy
cốt lên một cái hót nào đó xong rồi mấy
ông nên tự thuê hót hoặc là bạn nào
không có điều kiện thì có thể
nhắn nhắn riêng tôi thì tôi sẽ cung cấp
tài khoản hot cho ông này ông hot của
tôi ca nó cũng gọi là cũng bình thường
thôi thì để mày ông có thể đẩy lên đấy
để mà chạy không Một là dùng sắp domains
sắp đômen tức à kiểu dạng mà là kiểu
dạng cho Linh trang web của tôi là khi
tim.com nha chẳng hạn đúng không thì sắp
comment là cái răng trước này nó sửa A B
C như này thì hạ
Ừ cái ấy đằng trước này chắc là tôi sẽ
để tôi không biết để có được để số 20
Nhưng mà nếu mà kiểu thật sự là nhóm 21
hai nhóm 20 như thế này là sự để nhai
xong rồi đấy Kiểu thế đấy đêm mà
người ông sẽ đầy cốt lên trang web thì
mình chạy được cũng như là để mà tôi
cũng thể vào chạy thử được luôn cốt để
đánh giá code của mấy ông Nếu không hiểu
ý tôi không ạ
chỉ còn hoa mai thì sẽ là chấm lần lượt
hoa tất cả các nhóm kể cả tài liệu có
thứ
bộ đề thi đại thi 6
nhé
a
good này có tôi nhớ tôi chấm data pay
tài liệu rồi nhớ Thế
bây giờ tôi sẽ chấm
ý nghĩa nhằm bột đang bị thiếu thiếu
ở tuần 1 của tôi là phải có
phải có
Ừ thôi bảo là này thôi mở lại mày ông
xem nhé
Ừ mình đang phải tuần mấy rồi
ừ ừ
bạn liên kết này à
một tuần ba thì phân chia công việc lên
laptop ac tinh dữ liệu và vẽ mô phỏng
giao diện từng tính năng
một tuần bốn lại tiếp tục vẽ từng tính
năng bây giờ phải là tuần nào để phải
tuần năm rồi thì các bạn ở vẽ tính năng
các thứ thứ sau đó đẩy lên đẩy đẩy lên
ký chứ nhỉ nhóm này thiếu rồi để tôi mở
sheet tôi nói lại mời cả nhóm thiếu ai
vậy
là đánh giá này
à à
ô ồ
Vì sao cả trong màu đen rồi
thiếu à
không ạ Phải Phải có cốt rồi nhá Thứ hai
là
chú ý
khi thiếu Cốt và mô phỏng giao diện
ăn trái cây á dùng từ điển Photo hai nữa
là kiểu dặm là cái thiết kế giao diện
đấy à
em vẽ tính năng như thế nào ấy mình từng
hướng dẫn qua um hôm trước rồi Đấy mình
sẽ vẽ qua cái ở trên cái trang này mình
có có thông báo rồi kênh thông báo đấy
thì các bạn sẽ phải dựa trên kiểu dạng
các bạn sẽ vẽ những cái for nào mà các
bạn cảm thấy à là nó khá quan trọng là
sử như là cái phòng này Hôm trước mình
vẽ này
Ừ thôi mình đặt tên là xong rồi mình có
thể export thế này da mặt mình Esport
thế này ra chỗ dạng là ảnh như này được
mà đấy anh sẽ export ra để mình xem được
là với cái giao diện là kiểu giao diện
dụng giao diện này ra diện thêm mới bài
đăng này thì giao diện của chậm như thế
nào để mà vần thế là ra việtxem tất cả
bà đang bị nó phải trông như thế nào Vân
chẳng hạn thế có rất nhiều tính năng
quan trọng các bạn nó nó không chỉ đơn
thuần giống như đồ ăn một là cái giao
diện thêm sửa xóa mà nó khác rất nhiều
đúng ạ Hôm trước các bạn thấy là giao
diện này của tôi và và một lúc là không
chỉ mỗi thêm bài đăng mà thêm cả
công ty thêm cả ngôn ngữ này Vân đấy các
bạn phải luôn vẽ do diện này ra người có
kinh nghiệm rồi thì người ta không cần
điều đấy nhưng các bạn thì chưa nghe các
bạn sẽ vẽ ra rồi mà để mà biết được mình
cần làm gì và và đồng nghiệp của mình
cũng biết được và cùng cùng trao đổi với
nhau những ý tưởng Đấy đấy mấy ông phải
gọi thường suy à mà trao đổi nhau là nên
làm cái này như thế nào Nếu làm như nào
cho Để hôm nào tôi sẽ gọi trao đổi trực
tiếp với với các bạn cũng đang ngồi làm
cùng dự án với tôi thì mới ông sẽ hình
dung được hơn việc là là là bọn tôi cần
nên trao đổi những cái gì và nên thống
nhất những cái gì ra để hôm mà tôi sẽ
thử để mô trong mấy ông tôi thưa anh gọi
có Google mít nó có chia sẻ màn hình
cũng giờ gọi được nó về đâu discord thì
được chuyển sang màn hình nó hình như nó
hơi bị mà thỉnh thoảng mở
nó không ổn định à
anh nói chung nhóm 1 thì chưa có nhóm 1
là lâu lắm rồi không ăn gì đến đây cả
tôi dạo này thì cũng hơi bị công nhận
cũng cũng một phần do tôi dạo này tôi
hơi bận rộn tôi xuống Chúc mấy ông nhưng
mà Mấy ông không biết mày không có đăng
có đăng lên khẩu mấy em có làm không có
thể làm nhưng quên chưa đăng bọn chị
không làm thì nó lại trải qua đúng ạ bởi
vì cái này là đoán tốt cho bé ông mà
ông ngoại
Anh em nhóm hài nha nhóm 2 thì cũng chưa
có ơi
thứ hai tôi chưa kéo cô về
Vì sao chưa có gì nhỉ
chị xem nhé
gì nhỉ
nút kéo cốc không được
mất à
em đang kéo mày nghỉ không
anh ở đây ra rồi cái vừa nãy có vẻ là
không được nỗi gì đấy em tài liệu thì có
vẻ vẫn chưa có mấy chỉ có cốt thôi
a comment
a Beer vẫn chưa có gì cả em với chị đẩy
lên để tên gì để xem nhé xem lịch sử đó
à đã có shiping rồi nó sẽ đinh rồi tạm
Mai xin rồi nhưng mà
giao diện gì cả Ok Ok
tin để thích hợp và razr vậy mắc in
thanh toán Bác
ngã ba Tân Thanh toán thì nó không tính
hợp tác trên thửa bạn ở phân biệt giữa
khái niệm lắp tin với Pocket bag in là
ví dụ là Pocket trạng chat Facebook
nghĩa chỉ cần nhúng về mà dùng được nó
không cần phải cấu hình gì nhiều còn về
thanh toán thì ở nó vậy trackinh nó
Pocket Thế là mình sẽ phải cài đặt khá
nhiều mình phải tự cốt nhiều cái nữa lẽ
mình phải can thiệp của cả cốt chứ không
cần phải nhúng về dùng được đúng về
giống rượu iPhone những về dùng được thì
mới gọi khái niệm like cái con cái Sao
mờ nốt hôm trước là mình cũng phải mình
về cơ bản nó là Lee là và thư viện Tức
là sao nó ít hơn nó cũng dùng Pocket
nhưng mà nó ít hơn và nó vẫn phải về
mình một rồi gọi thằng này nó hay mình
có thể chương trình một tí thì thì đó là
cậu nhỏ không phải bắt ăn gì cả nó thư
viện thôi
Ê con chó Becgie là gần nhà ông Chỉ Còn
Những về sau cùng ngắm mỏng khai báo là
cặp ông khai báo là cậu ông gọi trực
tiếp đến đâu gọi trực tiếp đến fanpage
nào một phát là xong ngay không cần phải
không cần cài đặt gì thêm thì thì phát
ghi nó khái niệm như thế ông không can
thiệp vào cốt của nó
ừ ừ
xem lại hình chờ alo
Ở nhóm 2 Hình như là làm sao
ờ ờ
nhớ mày chưa có gì cả
Ừ ok tặng
ở tạm bỏ qua đấy nhóm 2 tiến độ có phải
là đang hít
Ừ tôi sẽ tôi diện tích ở đây là ích nhé
Chưa chưa đến tiếp theo nhóm thứ ba à
tại sao đây nó không kéo cốt lấy hộ tôi
nhỉ Đợi thì đợi thích tôi xem lại tôi
Cấu hình lại thế
Anh nhớ là cái key mát của tôi control-t
này là update phố check update làm nhỉ
Những phải kéo về cái này là tại sao nó
không phu về hộ mình
ở kiếp này
a bít ở đây gì mình có
em về update với cu khác nhau
ừ ừ
anh không
à à
để xem nhé update ở đây
em đang bị nhiều ý à
a Vẽ AH
a bit
I do not let anything for
chị khen update only the friends on
another However not match any things get
here update and make
em song ca tôi hơi yếu get toàn dùng cái
tôi hỗ trợ sẵn này mày không Mày không
đừng nên hi vọng gì nhiều
cho tôi Tôi không nói nó tôi rành cái vụ
này để tôi khuyên mấy ông Ờ
tê rồi
áo sơ mi mua nó bị thôi Cứ thẳng đến kết
quả được
quay đúng không
Ở
khu này Ừ thôi nha
xe container
em hỗ trợ Pantene
à à
khu về cho mỗi thằng này thôi để xem mà
ăn
thằng à
Blackberry class a
Nghe có vẻ mỗi thằng kia
à à
a refined option
a Smart Tivi video
Ok vậy
ở đầu tiên là thằng thứ ba đúng
ông bà có
à à
Ừ mai gì đấy mai này để chạy trên
electron à
ờ ờ
tích tôi dậy à kiểm tra phân tích tôi
tạm nốt lại đây thông ca nó bấm cho tôi
muốn có thời gian để chấm nhẹ không phải
thế Nhưng mà mấy cái này mấy ông vẫn có
thể tiếp tục làm nhé
ở
nhà ông bà ngoại phải đặt tên tôi đang
Em béo phải tôi tôi phải chị bảo mấy ông
ký ức mấy ông đặt tên nhóm để tôi tiện
tra chứ kiểu này tôi phải ngồi xem nào ạ
à à
nằm
ở chỗ ngồi tra lịch sử ngồi tra lịch sử
của quý tí đây có Min
ờ ờ
doc1
ba nó nghỉ Không không phải có mít chung
gì vậy
à Tôi đang lại xem kênh riêng của cái
lịch sử của nhóm mạnh như thế nào nếu
xem nhá Nó có cái vụ khái niện ở đây kíp
này
đi sâu
anh xô g
ở
đây nè
Ừ ông kia vẫn hỏi về
Ê cái code này gà mái ông đặt tên là mấy
ông à
không nên không phải đi ghi cái con nít
cách kia có mít thì tôi sẽ có tôi chỉ
mới ông cái Khi Con Nít chuyện cách đi
Viettel nhá
lô này
ờ ờ
em không biết à
xu hướng dẫn dùng từ hướng dẫn hướng dẫn
con nít
này
quy tắc viết nội dung để tôi để tôi xem
lại cứ nhớ hồi trước tôi từng ở
phải nên khi con nít nó như thế này à
thì nó sẽ kiểu là đầu tiên là sẽ có kiểu
là Thay tất cả loại loại có mít của ông
tiếp theo là là ông có thể nói là cụ thể
nó nó là cái gì Ví dụ ví dụ ở đây giả sử
là hôm nay tự update cốt thì tôi sẽ là
update như thế này sao tiếp theo là
update code
bà cụ thể update cái gì Thì đó sẽ là cái
ruộng là undead con ở đây là cao áp 3D
thôi ạ xong rồi đóng ngoặc như này hay
chấm như là cách ra xong rồi Cụ thể là
ông làm ở bên A admin hay ở gì admin
hoclien
này tiếp theo ông làm liên quan đến
thằng đối tượng nào nếu mà thực sự nó
liên quan cụ thể đến một đối tượng nào
đó là sự hôm trước là bài đăng kiểm đấy
khi nó sẽ là con nít cơ bản thì nó như
thế này còn về body hay là footer thì
ông tùy tùy ông cần nhưng mà cái này
Thật ra cũng tùy này nếu mà Mấy ông
không biết ở hôm nay cập nhật quá nhiều
sẽ chỉ ghi như thế này tên gì để mà khi
mà ông đẩy lên đẩy lên à
anh giống như công ty tôi đang dùng à
kênh this code để mà lót lại là anh em
đã có biết cái gì để lên bút chì kênh
nào ấy thì nó sẽ thường hay lấy cái tiêu
đề của cái con nít và thông báo cho mọi
người thì mọi người biết được ông vừa
mới làm cái gì Và thậm chí nếu không
thấy ở đây nó sẽ luôn hiển thị ra cái
tiêu đề ở đây này thì nên tiêu đề nó lên
có ý nghĩa tí không thì phí mất công ông
để maxxis ông kia update ai chẳng biết
bếp không ạ Cái này không nói chung
không phải dương nhỏ nhóm này nhá Cái
này là ngọn Nói chung ạ nghĩa là làm mấy
ông sẽ phải học cách để mà viết đấy
trong trường hợp mà để update cho mấy
ông thấy là còn thêm những cái nữa là
thích như này hoặc là phút a fish tất cả
viết tắt của Future nó là kiểu và tôi đã
tạo con tôi có tạo phím tắt cho rồi đấy
mà người ta phím tắt cho người uống xem
nhé Tao không bác làm như thế này giờ là
khi cho nó dài quà tặng phím tắt nó là
vào tuổi này cái
nhà thiết kế toán sự thì tất cả tôi sẽ
mỗi lần gọi cho fit ngay cái ca nhà ấy
hiểu tôi còn biết nói gì đó Thế thôi con
lừa như thế mà nếu hoàn toàn thể update
như này
nó sẽ là update một cái gì đó
khi tôi bị lỗi đấy update này
ờ ờ
ở mặt trận chí à
Thích và hotfix nữa nó sẽ còn thêm khái
niệm nữa là Phích một cái gì đó thích và
sửa lỗi một cái gì đó và Perfect như này
hotfix nó khác Phải xích để điểm gì
hotfix là không phải đẩy lên sớm nhanh
Bởi vì nó làm cái bớt với Hồng nghiêm
trọng sẽ là nguy hiểm mình cần phải đẩy
lên nhanh luôn Mình mình phải nói chung
là nó luôn Đạt nó cần sự ưu tiên rồi mà
7 lên sớm để mà khắc phục lỗi đây đương
nhiên là bây giờ dự án của mấy ông mình
nói chuyện công khai nên cũng ngọn Chưa
đâu quan vấn đề gì nguy hiểm cả đây thực
ra chỉ có fake sửa lỗi gì đó mà chị Đây
là thêm hẳn tính năng mới nhá hẳn một
chức năng mới thì sẽ như này cập nhật
một cái gì đó thì sẽ ghi như thế này Đấy
nó gửi cho tôi thường anh dùng 3 này
thôi cho dễ nhớ cái thực ra có nhiều anh
em có dùng thêm một cái nữa nó sẽ ra a
khái niệm là
Tao đố mày không biết cái này gì không
cho tra Google nhé ông ông nào kiểu gì
cũng phải ông người dùng ít rồi cô mới
không biết cái này là gì
Ừ nó viết tắt của từ gì
Vì theo kinh nghiệm của anh thì deli
Pocket bác khi nào cần thiết cho một
website có phòng TP cái này thì còn tùy
à
Ừ cái bài toán quan trọng nhất là em
hướng đến của trang web như thế nào cho
những ai dùng yếu là sửa cho mỗi em dùng
trắng ạ thì nó không cần nhiều pectin về
virus ạ Em không cần phải làm cái biết
em không còn sự chặt chẽ kiểu sự đúng là
nơi mà dữ liệu đấy hoặc cho cho cá nhân
em một vài người dùng thì được Em không
cần làm màu me Do diện em thể đơn giản
họ sẽ dung lẽ là ngoại đấy và
nói chung và cái này nó nó theo cái tính
năng của em thôi chứ Ảnh khó mà kiểu
hướng dẫn cụ thể trong các bạn được
nhưng mà còn những cái mà Mấy ông cần
nên cài thì vì sao tôi sẽ cho Cay Để Một
khi cốt đấy ví dụ là tôi không Dẫn mấy
ông kia thật là ví dụ giờ xử với tôi mở
cốt mấy ông đây là lỗi một đống đấy thì
tôi cài thêm khá nhiều cái để mà kiểu nó
chết cháu lỗi này nếu khéo nó đây à
anh không hiểu à Này không không hề có
cái class này chẳnghạn giả sử thế không
khó cái này do tôi chưa cài tôi chứ tải
ven đo về nó cứ tự động cảnh báo mà
không tìm thấy báo này chán thế hoặc cái
này là cái này thì à
Anh đang báo lỗi gì đó
Có nhiều thằng có cá này nó có hai hàng
có Glass này nó báo lỗi như là do là cái
này đang nhảy sang mục khác của tôi nên
nó bị thế không sao đấy nhớ ở đây Đây là
cái nó thằng yeah Hỗ trợ nó kèn báo lỗi
hộ tôi Hãy chọn thế thì tôi nghĩ à Mình
dùng mình Minh Trà Đúng rồi bạn kia đã
sở đúng cái cái từ này là Word in for
tourists Tất cả chỉ là Bang Bang là nữa
bà làm tâm cái gì đó ông Tại sao phải
con nít cái gặp ông đang làm rồi lên bởi
vì a Giả sử nhiều ông đang dùng máy ở
công ty hoặc à ấy cái đại loại là kiểu
đang làm trên công ty đang làm ở nhà
chẳng hạn thế Thì ông đẩy cốc lên trên
cái quen của ông thôi a sample của ông
chứ không phải đẩy lên
bố mẹ tôi giới thiệu trong mấy mấy ông
khái niệm về friend nó nó sẽ là kiểu à
theo cách hiểu tôi nha này
thì nó sẽ kiểu như thế này cho anh cái
ảnh này nó dễ này tôi thấy anh ấy về
hiểu gội đầu thôi trực chơi thiểu cần
ghi đâu nó sẽ rửa sao đây có một nhánh
Master ngày quan trọng nhất Hoàng ảnh
main đấy nó ngành quan trọng nhất đấy
ông sẽ chỉ lên đẩy những cái cốt mà chạy
được đã kiểm tra cá thử đã ngon lành
cành đào đẩy lên kẹp nhánh hay thôi thì
sao Lúc đầu ông sẽ tạo một cái quen
riêng của chính ông Sau đó thì ông sẽ
đứng nhà tạo cái này là cái thừa từ cái
thằng Masters đấy chắc chắn sau đó thì
ông sẽ cốt mọi thứ ấm sẽ đẩy có mít mọi
thứ lên trên đây Đấy sau khi mà nó thực
sự rất là ổn Ông kiểm tra chán chê ở
local tất cả trên máy cá nhân rồi nó ổn
rồi thì ông sẽ đẩy ông sẽ bớt nó lên
master đấy và tương tự người khác cũng
thấy sẽ tạo một kênh ngành riêng của
Chính họ sau đó thì họ làm xong họ tới
đây Masters đấy nhưng mà nhưng mà có
nhiều ví dụ là à ở Hưng Yên ở công ty
thì đương nhiên nó sẽ chia thêm nhiều
nhánh nữa cái gọi là con nhá là ngành
Điều rapper những đi lốp tất cảm chị ạ
nhánh để mà mấy cục đẩy lên đấy tán tỉnh
Nam nếu không sẽ
mà ông không mấy công tác ở Lục ở mày cá
nhân chưa đủ nha mấy ông sẽ phải đẩy lên
cái tính năng nữa tôi thậm chí à nó sẽ
con nhá ngành kinh tế cả những kiểu nó
giống
môi trường của nó thì giống hệt Master
gọi là a mua cho bọn nó giống hệt
borussen tức chỉ là môi trường thực tế
nhưng mà nhưng mà nó lại không phải là
cái bạn tông giao cho khách hàng sử dụng
thì mày ông mẹ nhưng mà nó là môi trường
Thực tế là nó có nào tôi bay thực tế nó
hỏi tao bay Còn nhát cái thứ gì nữa Nó
không có tính năng nhát thì đấy đấy thì
ông ông phải đẩy lên đấy mà thực sự chạy
thù cho ổn đã trước khi ông tẩm chính
hoàn toàn đấy thì nó sẽ có những cái
kiểu tách dược biệt riêng anh như thế ạ
bây giờ đương nhiên là ông làm hai người
với nhau thôi mà đợi chiếu là một mình
thì ông chỉ còn 12 nhá đủ rồi ốm sẽ có
một nhánh và nhánh kiểu cho chính bản
thân ông thì ông hoàn toàn thấy ông đầy
lên người cậu là sử ông đang cốt giờ ở
trên công ty Sau đó ông về nhà thì ông
muốn cần nói chung là cốt xong một ngày
thì nên đẩy lên lại nên để lên kể cả
dùng trên chính máy cá nhân để mà kiểu
ông không nên không nên thì họ không nên
giống tôi hiểu tôi cố tận ba bốn ngày
thúc đẩy lên nó rất nhiều file và lúc
đấy Ông cũng lời ghi chú thích vào từng
file thành ra là ông ghi toàn kiểu rất
là ngắn gọn kiểu âm bếp là cái gì đó còn
nếu mà ông ghi cụ thể ra để về sau mình
cha tôi đang cày một cái tiện ích để mà
phải xong tra được là tại ông thấy tiện
ích của tôi nó hiển thị tên ở bên cạnh
ngay này xuống ngày tháng này xong ngồi
kiểu đã đã có mi cái gì rồi tối thì ấn
để mà xem được lịch sử con nít này ai
lịch sử con nít của
cài đặt đã cập nhật ngày này như nào
toàn bộ hết ở đây cập nhật như thế nào
So sánh sáng đấy thì thì ông bắt buộc à
nên ghi con nít đúng cách tử tế kết hợp
việc là Nhi cụ thể rõ là a để người ta
hiểu cái dòng này cốt đoạn khó hiểu này
thì hồi trước ông ông ghi chú thích như
nào cho bạn đấy chẳng hạn thế chứ ghi
update thì sợ Chẳng hiểu cái gì cả đúng
thế nên à Mấy ông tôi đã từng nói qua
mấy ông về khái niệm nộ cốt rồi nộ cốt
phải Tức là sao nợ phải trả nặng nợ phải
trả Không ạ Nội cốt trứng gà lúc này ông
có thể lừa cô ít còn ngắn gọn thì cả chú
thích mọi thứ ra ngắn gọn về sau phải
trả đó là sao ông lại phải lại phải sửa
cái đoạn đấy nó sẽ rất là mệt cũng như
là cậu không hiểu được đoạn Ấy thằng kia
hay chính bản thân ông đã làm cái gì đấy
đâu ngon thì ông sẽ phải trả bằng cốc
thôi Nội có phải trả Ừ lúc nào ông lên
ngay từ bây giờ ông nên học cái cái cẩn
thận được qua như là tốt Được bao nhiêu
tuổi tốt thôi một cái đi làm được gì
cũng sẽ phải phải cẩn thận thôi Còn bây
giờ đang làm à Đang làm về cơ bản thì
vẫn đang tự do thoải mái Tôi vẫn không
thể xóa sao từng tất cả được thậm chí có
nhiều hôm nay còn không nghe buổi này
chẳng ạ Nên là càng khó nhưng mà
Ừ ông vào ngay được thì tội tôi có tôi
góp ý thế đúng không ạ Mình không cần
phải cải thiện mày cái vụ đấy
các bạn này cũng cốt pha nhiều rất nhiều
nhưng mà cái đoạn chú thích thì có vẻ
đang hơi bị đăng chưa có tôi cũng chưa
thấy có cài đó hả Ừ tôi chưa thấy có cái
phần mô phỏng giao diện
nếu phải bổ sung tôi
Em
thiếu một phòng giao diện không ạ ngắm
một thì có mô phỏng diện Có cốc chưa có
Quốc rồi ở Trung à
ở
những mô phỏng diện nhé
nghe ngóng
ờ ờ
ngờ Tại sao phê em nhỉ
vé máy bay như à
Anh Khôi phục cài gốc thì vậy
Anh Khôi phục thành góp gì vậy Không nhớ
gì
ừ ừ
3 5 4 4
254 là
liệu ô tô khách sạn tại sao có tận hai
cái cốt ở trong ngày này
liệu rồi
ở mức tài liệu rồi xem nha xem đít
ờ ờ
tôi sẽ viết tắt để con thương hát đi con
hát đi play rồi con duchiep hát đi
ở Kon Tum ship hát
Em chưa có đúng không
Sao history đi
ừ ừ
ở forum actions
Ê con chó Suýt hạn
anh mùa này
đi lại còn đòi ship hát ở đây xem
con nít này do document cái này nhưng bị
xóa rồi
một ngày như bị xóa rồi nè
các bạn trong cơ sở liệu có tính năng số
thể hiện chưa có cái mô phỏng
các bạn đã bị thiếu quá à
thì tôi thường hay hướng dẫn miếu này
thế là mấy ông sẽ hiểu dạng là kẹo
cha mẹ ông cốt xong cái gì đó Sao mày
cũng đẩy lên hình cuối buổi Mọi khi cưới
buổi tôi vẫn thường hay để cốt lên chồng
em xem mà chọn chọn từng file gì đó đẩy
lên
các bạn phác thảo idea
I mean I
ở Milan đây chưa có gì cả
khi xu t
b b i anh chưa có gì cả nhóm này đang
chưa có gì cả mà chiếu á
A4 thì thừa cốt nhưng mà cũng thiếu mô
phỏng nó diện còn nhằm năm này thiếu cả
hai đúng không là cốt và mô phỏng nói
chuyện ấy chi tiết được nhiều nhóm phết
nhỉ Chấm hết tất cả nhóm này ờ ờ
Vì sao
ừ ừ
Vì sao bay mất cái không thích
xe của Minh đây
diện hội đâu chậm ông về cái mô phỏng
chưa Cái ông cần mô phỏng chưa đã
1562 còn thiếu này có vẻ tất cả nhà
không Tất cả nhóm bây giờ đều đang thiếu
nha
bây giờ tôi chưa Chưa tải về thôi đợi
thì đã tải về
Chú Đại Bi
ê ê
357 vẫn đang ấy cô thì phải
ờ ờ
Ừ đợi tí có khi xóa Sửu tháng 7 đi xong
rồi mất lại
làm Toán chưa nhá
cả
nhóm vừa rồi là nhóm sáu nghỉ ngắm sao
rồi ok 58 nhé Nó 8 thì làm gì rồi nghỉ
chưa đầy cốt lên đúng không Chưa có mô
phỏng đúng không
357 Sao chậm vậy nha Còn chống suy hao
này
về crm
nhóm này làm
vợ kinh khủng fat
chỗ này chỗ Về xí nghiệp nhưng mà
thế nào
à à
thị ra cái mô phỏng nó diện thôi nhỉ
ở nhà ông này mới chỉ đang làm à Mua đồ
các thử thôi chứ có gì cả trường mô
phỏng chuẩn vẫn chưa có cái tôi cần à
Anh Tạm thời thì tôi chưa chầm lấy cốt
mẹ mày ông được mấy ông Cư cốt Thôi kệ
tôi sẽ Chậm qua mô phỏng chứ tôi không
thể chấm qua giao diện được về tôi không
đưa tôi tại Cốt về lần lượt chạy thử thì
chưa chưa Cho làm vụ đấy
a cho nhóm lại thiếu đâu ạ
các nhóm chim
nữ Ca sỹ hát này
a bed with me lần cuối bạn trẻ babyme
thôi mở file eps em à
diện cơ sở dữ liệu ok à kiểm tra lại
kiểm tra
à à
kiểm tra lại phân tích ok à
năm 11 có
số
nhà 11 thì tạm nghỉ rồi nhóm 12A
u12a
đi mất
Ừ tao có mức ở đây rồi đấy
Ai Cập nhật Dortmund
em có thêm mục báo comment ok
hồ sơ đồ sơ đồ
tài liệu phân tích đối tượng và thiết kế
à à
em vẫn chưa có sơ đồ bạn chữa sơ đồ kiểu
Tôi cần nó lắm nha
khi sex
Em đang làm chỗ này rồi
à à
chưa liên lạc được bỏ qua
Ừ
anh hôm nay ẩn đĩa
cái cốt ghi Mệnh 2 tuần qua mấy ông chỉ
ngồi cốc à
Ê mày không cần phải phân tích chứ
anh alo tôi yêu cầu mấy ông ở cần phân
tích mà tôi cần mấy ông có được hay sao
mấy tuần qua mấy ông chỉ mới Cốc
ai mà Chắc là hôm nay sẽ chân chích lại
không mai sẽ về đăng thông báo hướng
ừ ừ
Ê mày có nhóm nào ngồi phân tích mô
phỏng cả
có ai chưa
không làm đâu không chấm Cái này không
ổn rồi
số comment chỉ có thể tài liệu nào xem
A và kiểm tra phân tích đi à
từ nhỏ mắt ở nhóm 14
rồi mai chị trần mô phỏng thôi mấy ông
cố tôi gì tôi tôi chơi chấm mấy ông về
cốt mấy ông phải có cái mô phỏng giao
diện thì tôi mới hình dung được và với
ông Phân tích đúng hay sai về cái kiểu
mà không cần phải làm những cái giao
diện trông như thế nào Nếu hôm đấy tôi
lấy mình sẽ biết chứ
chồng cái gì à
cho
tôi tôi có đăng thông báo mà tôi đang
thông báo dẫn hai tuần chỉ ngồi làm về
cái mỗi Ngô Phòng
A và mua phòng có diện của mấy ông mình
chưa có nếu mà sinh viên tôi ở trên lớp
đấy thì tôi sẽ bắp 2 tuần Đấy gần như
tôi sẽ gửi Bác ngày nào lên mang theo
giấy bút ngồi vẽ không ngồi cốt đúng rồi
nó gọi là móc áp cũng đúng nó gọi vô tô
thai cũng đúng nó gọi là nói chung là nó
bản thiết kế về cả giao diện sơ qua là
hình dung được là trang web có những cái
có giao dịch có cái kiểu cái khuôn cái
form là trông như thế nào nếu mình ông ạ
Mấy ông không thể làm mấy cái đấy thì
làm sao mày ông hình dung được là trang
web của ông cần có những tính năng gì
anh Bởi vì em ấy ông Khi mà béo làm cái
đấy mà không dẫn người nghĩ tính năng
luôn là bản chất là khi thêm cái gỗ khi
thêm điểm danh thì nếu không làm như thế
nào thêm điểm nếu không làm nha thêm
điểm lần lượt thằng bạn ạ rồi thêm sinh
viên để làm được làm như nào ấy chẳng
hạn thế Nếu người Mô Phỏng hết tất cả
đúng đấy ra nhé
ừ ừ
này làm làm nhiều quá cập nhật thêm sửa
xóa nhiều quá mà cái tôi cần thì không
có
khi mở xóa lúc nào chẳng được
ừ ừ
e56 có gì cả đậu xanh ngày 17
anh thiếu thiếu rất nhiều ờ
Xem tiếp
ờ ờ năm 18
ừ ừ
em chọn em Không chọn anh được vẫn này
thủ công gõ là được tay từng cái muộn về
kê
đi đám ma
Anh mua rồi Nhà 18
38 không có xong số nhà 18
tích hết rồi
ừ ừ
a spin Desire ở Châu Đốc Tại sợ có
công ty Screen Write ảnh
điểm thi
Ừ cũng được ra là ý tôi là phải cụ thể
xem sửa xóa bất kỳ cái gì cũng nên có
xem sửa xóa hay cái gì đó cho bảo là mỗi
xem thôi Được sẽ là cái gì thơm mà học
kì à
a cho chồng ngay
từ khóa học là số 10 cái gì đó đây đúng
không
em gà thì à để chấm bắt đầu chậm nhé
này là bạn ấy đang nghĩ sao phải tính
năng quan trọng là điểm thi hay cái gì
đó ở bên bạn đấy là đây quản lý điểm học
viên mà cái tí nào quan trọng đối với
bạn đấy sẽ là liên quan điểm nhưng mà
nhưng mà mình không mình không thể làm
cái này đầu tiên rồi mình làm cái gì đầu
tiên mình sẽ là thêm thêm chương trình
đào tạo hay thêm một cái gì đó Đầu Tiên
chứ không phải là những cái này như là
cái này phải là
anh phải để ở dưới cùng để sau mình sẽ
phải làm những cái mình phải phân tích
những cái trước đã chứ nhỉ Phân tích
những cái trước đã gửi mình hình dung
theo theo kiểu là theo xuôi bài toán
xuôi của bài toán đấy đấy lẽ mình sẽ
cái này giống như bạn ấy bảo làm nên
khung chương trình thế này chẳng hạn tại
các chợ thứ sau đó thì sau đó thì cont
học này sau đó lớp này song sinh viên
này sau đó thì mới có điểm đấy nhỉ Mấy
cái này thì bạn tôi
vì tôi nghĩa là cái này tôi khó bạn thân
tôi nhìn nó khó một chấm bởi vì à mà
cũng chẳng biết được Kiểu ở đầu đoạn đầu
bạn ấy khó những cái gì có Không có một
cái thứ tự gì đây cả
ở đoạn này người dùng phải sửa lại nghĩ
em bé ông sẽ phải làm đúng thứ tự kiểu
người dùng đầu tiên người dùng vào sẽ
nhìn cái gì gần như thế sau đó lên đầu
tiên là khi người dùng mới dùng cái phần
mềm của ông thì nó sẽ nhìn thấy đi đầu
tiên đấy Sau đó thì mình sẽ làm mình cái
gì ABC Cái rét hãy cứ thể thay thế cái
lần lượt theo thứ tự ưu thế đáng cả cái
Manu mày cũng phải vẽ ra nhá cũng phải
vẽ cái Menu ra là menu của ông thì nên
có những cái gì
ở đây ví dụ giả sử như hồi trước tôi
phân tích đó là mày ngu ấy thì ví dụ
điển hình là menu của một cái một cái
Giả sử một cái phần mềm quản lý quản lý
học viện như kiểu phần mềm quản lý điểm
nhấn này đã hạn thì mấy ông sẽ có mẹ ông
sẽ chia menu menu 2 cấp nên lợi thế và
nên có theo khái niệm là là đầu năm là
sự đầu năm đầu năm mình sẽ làm gì đấy
chẳng hạn thế sau đó giữa năm và cuối
năm chẳng hạn thế đầu năm thì nó sẽ làm
gì đầu năm nó sẽ là thêm chương trình
đào tạo
anh chạy thế môn học
ấy sẽ hạ thế thêm
lớp học rồi thêm sinh viên nào ạ là xu
thế là sự thế
Ở đây ít nhất là phải như thế số tiếp
theo Đến giữa năm giữa 5.000 khi mẫu
thêm hết toàn bộ rồi thì gần như là ông
sẽ chỉ có là nhập điểm chè mạn
Nhà Máy Kẹo thế nhập nhập điểm tia ghi
nhập điểm Nhưng bản chất là nó sẽ xem
điểm xã hội mà vào vần trong này có rất
nhiều từ nhập điểm này nó nói một tình
nào rất rộng bao gồm cả xem và nhập cập
nhật điểm Vân bác cuối năm thì mình sẽ
sẽ là những cái đúc kết ra được từ những
cái này không ạ đó thống kê
thống kê ở đây nó rất rộng có hệ thống
kê kiểu dạng là thống kê tốt nghiệp sẽ
mà sinh viên này có thể có đủ điều kiện
lên lớp không ai Vân sinh viên nào còn
hậu môn nào thì nó sẽ là kiểu dạng mà
tổng kết điểm chẳng hạn và là danh sách
cô sinh viên
thi lại chẳng hạn sự thế
là xử thế ông ạ giữa năm này ông có thể
là kiểu Xem danh sách sinh viên cũng
được sách sinh viên kéo khóa chẳng hạn
đấy Nghĩa còn những cái tính năng kiểu
như này người mấy ông phải đặt tân mình
vào người dùng gồm mấy ông sẽ mấy ông có
phân tích ra được là người dùng thực sự
là người dùng cần những tính năng nào và
phải ghi nó kẹo dễ hiểu bản chất ở bằng
Sau đó thì mình sẽ phải làm những cái gì
đấy ví dụ Giả sử mấy ông Thiết kế ra cái
menu như này rồi Hôm nay tôi sẽ tôi sẽ
hiểu trong tuần này tôi yêu cầu mấy ông
ngồi viết thiết kế ra cái menu như thế
này đã sau đó thì người ông sẽ giữa ở
cái từng cái này là từng tính năng này
không phải là cái Phân tích tính năng
của mấy ông thấy phân tích hồi trước Văn
Bộ là kiểu
quản lý cái này còn lý kia có bao nhiêu
bạc của Lý bấy nhiêu cái không Không
phải như thế em phải từng cái Menu này
từng tính năng này Đấy sau đó thì mấy
ông Tư cái này suy ra được khi bấm vào
cái này nó sẽ nhảy đến cái form nào và
trong người foam đấy có cái nút để bấm
nhảy sang phải phom khác nữa không Không
phải phân tích hết ra tất cả đúng vậy
mấy ông nhìn như này hình dung nó ạ
Anh hiểu hiểu hiểu Tôi đang cần gì không
đấy
ở đây không có tham ăn những 30 mấy ông
đã ngon xem dạo này có thấy thoáng mát
Diệp
a mắt thì có tôi còn giải đáp hỗ trợ
luôn cho Mấy ông bà cháu Các bạn khác
con đoạn ai mà hiểu là có ngờ là mình
không phải làm được nha khi con Thắm áo
kiểu Ý
anh alo
A Gọi giáo viên tôi sẽ lấy bao điểm danh
điểm danh bạn hết cả lên sinh viên vào
điểm danh tới tấp
Ừ Ok nói suông mà bạn này tạm chốt như
thế này nhá thì ông sẽ phải ngồi vẽ menu
kiểu kiểu ngay xuống với ông sẽ phải từ
những cái tính năng này xảy ra được
những cái mô tô hay những cái giao diện
mấy cái móc gì đó để mã Hình dung là
được là mình cần phải làm sự cần làm cái
gì
ờ ờ đúng nghĩa làm chơi ở nhảy sang cái
phom gì đó không cần nút cũng được Nhưng
mà mình phải ghi rõ ra là sau đó như nào
Bước 1 Bước 2 là cái gì không
anh em muốn học từ đầu thì nên bắt đầu
từ video này mình có danh sách list khóa
cơ bản đấy thì các bạn à Bạn xem từ khóa
các bạn chưa Nhá làm chưa hoặc cơ bản và
kể queo ý bạn hãy học xong xong rồi đấy
ở sông à nhóm nhóm 18 có rồi nhưng mà
vẫn cần phải sửa lại nhá Thôi cứ sửa lại
thì sao không cần lấy nốt lại đây
Alo nhóm 18 thì có đây nhỉ 18 bất ngờ
tạm Ẩn nhóm 18 ngõ 59 đây Ok rồi đấy
Long 20 này
các thứ thử thôi chồng nghe xịn
khi phân tích thiết kế
có lẽ giao diện OK nhờ tôi muốn mấy ông
kẹo có cái kiểu ảnh hay luôn chứ không
phải vuốt kia nếu mà bất kia thôi ra vừa
rồi có cái 20 Kiểu mình sẽ phân rõ là
một hai là gì nhưng mà nhưng mà vừa rồi
thì đó của bạn đấy lại bị ở bị ngược quá
Cái này cần phải lên trên được hạn không
có
phòng đặt lịch hẹn trống hay nghỉ ở
ở
đây kiểu giao diện cho sóng ngày bạn ấy
có vẻ khá có tâm tư này
Ừ ừ
giá nghiệm chữa bệnh nhân tiểu sử đây
Bạn làm kiểu này khá hay
đầu tiên là trang web của ông đầu tiên
phải xem tất cả các các đầu tiên phải
tìm kiếm đã tìm kiếm các thứ thứ
à Xong rồi mới đến cái form Đặt lịch
nóng lạnh đấy ok tên tên người đăng ký
em mặc định ở điện cái này xong cái này
nó có thể tự động Điền mà mình sửa lại
cũng được cái hoặc cả không Mình có tích
Từ Đây là kiểu thông tin đây bệnh nhân
cũng và thông tin về đăng ký luôn cũng
được chọn một trong hai Còn nếu bỏ cái
cái cái đi thì sẽ nhìn thấy cô mai cũng
được cái rơi tính Ok mày cho tao bao giờ
mình ok ngày sinh Ok mất đi sức khỏe cậu
ngay cho đơn giản ngoại ngày tháng năm
giao diện Ôi được Tôi thấy cái này rồi
xem còn chê được cái gì không nhé sẽ
chơi được game nhé
lịch nghe nó sẽ không cho Ờ kiểu gọi
điện trực tiếp cho bác sĩ đâu cũng không
còn nhắn tin trực tiếp và bác sĩ bởi Nếu
thế thì bệnh nhân không cần phải tốn
tiền để mà đến khám nữa sẽ liên lạc chủ
động ghi âm nên thành ra là không nên
Còn nút này đây cùng lắm là sẽ có nút
luôn này Mixer ở đây để mà để mà liên hệ
với Chăm sóc khách hàng thôi
trực tiếp thời gian có mẹ là cái gì đấy
à nghĩa làm chuyện đó bác sĩ đúng không
bác sĩ ra xem đúng không Hay như nào
Ừ cái này ra diện là gì nhỉ nó hiện này
giao diện của bên nào
làm như này lý tưởng hơn thì tách tách
ra nó là bác thêm mấy cái thông mục nữa
đấy với bác sĩ nào với khách hàng nào
thưa thứ thì ổn hơn mày ông hiểu tôi
không ạ khách hàng thì sẽ nhìn thấy cái
gì Một là gì hay là gì ba là gì nó theo
đúng cái đấy mấy ông nên làm xuôi rồi
toán chứ không cái sao tôi khó bản thân
thôi
nghĩ ở của bên like đâu Ờ
xem chi tiết
ờ ờ không mấy cái này lại không phải
những cái thứ ưu tiên để nó sẽ duyệt với
ông đấy Đấy do tôi bảo mày không cần sửa
cái mà xét duyệt nó sẽ phải bị ra lại là
ngày nào bác sĩ là đấy và mô tả là gì để
xem có phù hợp với các bác sĩ Lệ không
sẽ chẳng hạn thế sau đó mình xong rồi
mới có số điện thoại và tên
email gì đó để mình bấm vào thì mình sẽ
là gọi được người ta sau khi mà liên lạc
được rồi thì mình mới xác nhận ông ạ
phải định ra hết ở đây chứ không thì
người dùng sẽ khó chịu
ở đây dùng sẽ bấm liên tục xe và nó vẫn
thể sắp xếp ưu tiên và theo là lịch gần
nhất đồng ngoại
nếu hiểu chứ không ạ Đây
à à
không cần
không cần nói thêm gì cả
anh không cần đánh dấu thêm gì cả
a review Of You
quản lý chương trình học
mã số mã Môn
một số lớp số học viên cái này cái đi
anh cho biết giao diện là để làm gì đã
diện này là thường có biểu à Cái giao
diện này có thể là
anh
không để ý gì nhỉ
ảnh em đúng không
có ai không phải một cái Mã Pí kà giao
diện này đúng là không thể làm gì thật
theo tôi đang thế Cái này để làm gì
À nhầm nổi
nhé ở quản lý cái gì ở đây
em tính năng này tính năng Tôi không
biết làm gì nếu ở người dùng vào xem còn
đi lớp
Ừ ừ
quản lý lớp thì nên hiển thị ra cánh ở
bên trên này để chọn khóa rồi mình thì
cả lớp mà chọn chơi nhờ tạo với nhiều
Địa lớp chứ không về xong có rất nhiều
lớp và ông Mạnh thứ cái thứ hai đó không
phải sắp xếp lớp theo lớp gần nhất lớp
10 tạo gần nhất hay gì đó chứ không phải
lại hiển thị lớp cũ nhưng ai bởi có lớp
nó tốt nghiệp sư rồi ông hiển thị ra
chẳng làm gì cả thứ hai là lớp phải theo
môn à Cái hình ở đây là hình như là bạn
ấy làm là mua
cách làm à ạ độ mẹ lớp bổ túc thằng buồn
em ạ thì phải
Ừ ông sẽ cần hiển thị ra thêm ở đây
ngoài số học viên là ông Còn hiển thị ra
đây ra là thời gian kết thúc thời gian
bắt đầu của lớp đấy lớp gì và có thể
tích luôn ở đây là kết thúc hai bắt đầu
hay gì đó chẳng thấy Vân đấy
anh cũng phải có nhập bằng Excel chứ
không phải Mỗi suất ăn
đánh số ngay nó sẽ kiểu sắp xếp cả ngay
nhưng mỗi tội Bạn đặt tên như này thì nó
thành vô nghĩa
gì đấy Mày không thể không Mình đang bị
Ưu tiên những cái mà mình không thường
xuyên xem thống kê ra cũng ít khi xem
thường hãy vào đây để quản lý những cái
gì đó Ưu tiên những người đấy phải đẩy
cả đẩy lên trên mấy cái này để dưới cùng
này có hiểu nó gần nhiều thích cái đấy
cho nó trong máy lu thứ hai bấm vào nó
mình chị đã để để người ta người dùng
chú trọng những cái quan trọng hơn đấy
chứ không ưu tiên mấy cái này lên trên
như thế này cái này thì
số tài khoản hệ thống có student Ừ với
lại
à à
thống kê cậu ngay hệ thống kê này thật à
trồng cây cho vui thôi vẫn là giống kiểu
đón một thùng kê vui thống về thống kê
kiểu quan trọng hơn nó sẽ còn liên quan
nhiều hơn nữa giống kiểu lại không nên
so sánh từng lớp kiểu kiểu như thế này
mà so sánh tỷ lệ phần trăm của các lớp
đấy đấy Cái thứ nhất tỷ lệ phần trăm của
Tuấn bớp là nó nghỉ học đi học ngày bao
nhiêu chứ không phải là thống kê xem mà
lớp nào nghỉ học nhiều hơn lớp nào là số
lượng sinh viên hay lớp khác nhau đứng
yên nghỉ học sẽ khác nhau cái gì nhất
của ai là
theo dõi được theo từng ấn vào chi tiết
thì sẽ xem được từng sinh viên cơ hội
việc làm và biết được thông tin của cái
giáo viên lớp đấy là gì chẳng hạn vào
Vân
có nhiều cái nữa cơ trồng cây này cho
cho vui thôi
Bây giờ tôi đang nói đấy nghĩa là mấy
ông mấy ông vì ông thư ra đây mới vẫn
chị ý tưởng thôi nhưng mà tôi đang bổ
sung mày không ấy Mày không cần phải
thực hiện rồi đấy hả ông ấy cũng mỗi
nhanh đẹp ạ
xe lửa
chỉ mới gần đây mới gần đây
vì vậy chị đánh vẫn thiếu nhiều nhiều
nhiều lắm à
bộ phim sex gì đấy
ở Mia Ấm remix
ừ ừ
ở nhóm 24
gì quà cốc thôi chưa có gì cả Vẫn thiếu
à cô
à à
Âm Nhạc trước đi 525
a a date With Me
cho redmi vỡ để ngoài kê sơ đồ thực thể
ế chưa có gì
anh chỉ có sơ đồ về thôi
Ông mày chả có gì mấy chấm nhỉ
Nhớ mày cầm kiểm tra phân tích ok
a tiếp theo ngày mai sóng
chưa làm phân tích hiểu về phân tích rồi
mai 7:00 ca mới này cũng chẳng có cái gì
cả
cả Ok Nói chung là bữa hôm nay thì à
em cũng chỉ chấm đồng mức tương đối chưa
có cái gì đấy cả để mà chắn cho mấy ông
nhưng mà Mấy ông cũng hình dung được là
mày ông đang thiếu cái đi rồi ông ạ à
Ở nhóm 2 tạ a12 nghỉ rồi
Ừ ok ok ok
Ừ ok
Linh là đi nhóm 28
em tính nhà để tí nữa
em nghe cái này là đang bị sang nhóm nào
nhỉ
và tôi Xóa ngay đi cloud lại vậy
ở trạm xăng
A8 đúng không
anh sex lâu ngày 28 đấy
ở nhưng vẫn thiếu với các bạn thì ông
vẫn thiếu khác gì đâu đúng không bổ bổ
sung bổ sung mơ anh nhá
ừ ừ
vẫn phải bổ sung
E52 Vừa nãy ra là cái gì nhé sữa đấy rồi
nói chung Tôi tích ở đây thì tôi kiểm
tra mà kiểm tra lại hết tất cả nhóm vào
thấy thiếu cái gì đó thì mấy nhóm tự
giác bổ sung thôi Cuộc sống ngồi tôi sẽ
chấm sau A
ờ ờ
bảo rồi Mày không phải ngồi vẽ ngồi vẽ
poster ta như là vẽ xong rồi xuất ra ảnh
xong rồi ghi tên này nó cho mọi thứ
không ạ Nếu phải làm à
à cẩn thận phân tích đoạn này rất là cẩn
thận trước khi bắt đầu cốt họ hôm trước
mấy ông thấy tôi mười ngọn gọi là với
đoạn này không phải để vui không ạ mày
không sẽ phải làm rất cẩn thận mấy cái
đoạn này để mà thậm chí là tôi còn chưa
yêu cầu mấy ông bấm vào cái nút này bản
chất nó sẽ hiển thị ra gì cơ đấy do mà
hồi trước tôi bắt cần sinh viên tôi bắt
cần là chuẩn bị giấy bút để ngồi vẽ ra
A4 là nhanh nhất đỡ phải ngồi cái Hạnh
nha tự nhiên nó không được đẹp như thời
gian mình chỉ cần phát sao ý tưởng thôi
Nếu không hiểu cái phát khảo ý tưởng
liên liên tục thì mới làm lao động của
sản phẩm thì gì đó chứ không phải cậu
à Hôm nay cậu cứ cắm đầu vào cốt cắm đầu
vào cốt Không khiến cho mình tiến hành
một lập trình viên một developer mà mình
sẽ kodo tất cả mình gõ lại những cái gì
mình biết thôi Hiểu không một lập trình
viên còn deeper là mình sẽ phân tích xem
à vấn đề thực sự là cái gì nhân cần mình
cần phải làm những cái gì để ra được
những sản phẩm đó nếu phải phân tích
điều đấy thì đấy mà công việc của lập
trình viên đang hướng đến cho mấy ông đồ
án này là phải chuyên nghiệp như thế là
phải thành Suneo
từ Juno desino chứ không phải là fan
cũng không phải là kiểu dạng mà mới học
tốt như đón một ngày là mấy ông sẽ phải
làm phân tích rất là chi tiết cẩn thận
tất cả mấy vụ này
cả nhóm Vừa nãy có cũng có nhóm phân
tích rồi đấy Cái nhóm Đặt lịch hẹn Vừa
nãy có mỗi cái phần đặt lịch hẹn thể chi
tiết cẩn thận cũng một còn là nơi sau
hiện cũng vẫn vẫn chưa được nhiều Vẫn
Chưa chuẩn lắm nhưng mà Đấy em bảo ông
hoàn toàn thế
tham khảo thôi chồng nhưng để mấy ông
tham khảo những nhóm khác Ok để thế thì
tôi xin phép là bây giờ mình sẽ sắp xếp
mình sự sắp xếp lại lịch dạy nhá nghĩa
là 35 này rồi vẫn sẽ dậy cốt còn thứ 7
hàng tuần như thế này tôi sẽ buổi tâm sự
như thế này chia sẻ không đôi khi là
chúng ta chỉ tâm sự nói chuyện bình
thường nó không cầm cố tình cả chỗ không
học cuối tuần và tôi sẽ thứ bảy tuần là
tội sẽ chấm đều ngoan sẽ chấm đồ án cho
mấy ông này để mà tôi sẽ sát sao mấy ông
cụ này chứ mấy tuần này tôi đang bận dạy
và tôi cũng đang có nhiều vấn đề thật
nên là cũng hơi là mấy ông nên uống hết
toa
Ừ đúng rồi thiếu ha cái vừa Tôi vừa đánh
dấu thiếu quá cái đánh dấu thiếu là
thiếu nhiều lắm không phải mỗi cái mô
phỏng Hiếu là thiếu nhiều lắm rồi thấy
thiếu
khi con ạ con mèo Ông thấy cảm thấy là
bé ông thiếu cái gì thì béo phải xem lại
cái tôi thông báo ấy là mày là tuần tuần
nào Tuần nào đấy tí cho lại thông báo
đến toàn năm mấy ông bây giờ còn đang
còn đang chưa làm xong phần 2 phần 3 đấy
100 tháng 10 Thôi đi dạy ở bên FPT cơ
cho là đúng à Mày gần đây chuyện công ty
này rồi Chuyện tình cảm nhiều cái ứng
dụng kiếm tôi khá bận à Tôi cũng làm
thêm và dự án cá nhân nữa Ừ khi nào tôi
làm xong tôi sẽ không hay xuống xe cái
trang chia sẻ nhà thấy nó cả thêm vài
cái nữa Nói chung là tôi cũng hơi bị lơ
làm tí tôi dậy vẫn dậy nhờ có hơi bị lơ
là với Khoản ạ ra sao độ án cho bé ông
hàm cho làm cho kiểu mấy ông đang mỗi
ông một tí này à
À tôi dậy sẽ là dậy ở cơ sở Bên Anh Duy
Tân và là FPT academy tất gà dạy cho
cũng là cậu vector Hình như là dạy nó
faso và cho Ninh cho cả Junio có thử thứ
chứ không phải là đại học FPT Đại học Y
Tây thì tôi không biết được về sau về
sau tính còn hiện tại thì tôi định dạy
buổi tối gần đây thì chắc là bệnh gì Tân
thôi không thể lên Hòa lạc được
tự động thêm cái đi bác 3 mà không phần
cần phải cài lại
Anh không ngờ em sẽ phải luôn tải lại à
phải lại cái đi bước 3 để em cài vào rồi
thì Nhưng mà khi em cài sẵn trên máy rồi
thì nó sẽ loa thử cách từ bản chất là
khi em Tải cài các tiện ích gì rồi
thường em nói lại trong cách ở trên máy
nên là em tải về vọng anh có cài nó
nhanh hơn
em nhỉ
Anh ở tra buổi hôm nay tạm kết thúc đấy
nhé Bố mày Tôi không cần phải tôi không
cũng không muốn nói nhiều mây
à À đúng rồi chia sẻ nốt hai cái hay ho
anh em đang ít ở đây tôi thì tôi lại
thích chia sẻ à
ở đầu tiên là cái tiện ích ai Striker
này chẳng mấy ông cha cái ra luôn rồi
Cái này à Nó tên là và bảo vệ mắt ra sao
nó không hiểu khiến cho màn hình Ông có
cần gì đâu mà nó sẽ kiểu tự động để
thông báo nho có khái niệm là 20 20 20
tất cả nó sẽ là 20 phút họ sẽ thông báo
cho ông và ông nên nhìn ra xa 20m trong
vòng 20 giây và ông cài tiện ích này kết
hợp với việc là
à Dạ cậu à cái bát rau google photo của
tôi đó là nó là như thế này kiểu đợi tí
thôi lên Google photo tôi xem có ảnh thì
khi bị phản cảm đó không xóa xóa đi
không biết đâu đấy Anh tính nóng quá
nhạy cảm quá
I do
ờ ờ
Tôi chả vondelpark drought đ
à à
trên giấy tờ cái gì đó
cho Windows và cũng tạo ra được một cái
tiện ích rất là hai cái đây tôi như tôi
gửi cho anh Mạnh Tuấn tệ ra cho tôi gửi
lại cho mấy ông luôn
đây có hỗ trợ Mac Windows cần tải về
thôi
khi download free giá sỉ
Ừ tôi chưa cài trên máy này nhà Ông thấy
là là giao diện của tôi vẫn là ưu tiên
nha nhớ về tôi sẽ cài trong máy cũng xem
để mua luôn không có nhiều để mua luôn
tủ lạnh Xóa hết mấy cái này Mày cài
không cần tập thể đi
ủy ban này ở đây là mấy ông sẽ có thể
kết nối đến nhiều tài khoản của mấy ông
của tôi sẽ google photo này
Ừ thôi Không thể để cho mày ông xem kĩ
của tôi được 18 triệu cho bên anh nhé
nào thì ở Nếu mấy ông muốn nếu mấy ông
muốn tôi sẽ tạo cho mấy ông một cái tôi
đã tạo sẵn một cái album rồi và mấy ông
tôi thấy áp này ông vào album đấy tôi
nếu chỉ còn chọn cái À à theo về album
Mình đã được chia sẻ nè là được rất là
hay mặc định của tôi như huyết album này
tôi sẽ để cứ thường là để để cho mày Ông
mày ông đỡ lag khi mà nó luôn Chạy lên
và nên theo cả cái tiện ích này nên để
20 phút một lần đấy mà tôi thích nhất ở
đây là bởi cái ảnh của tôi nó sẽ kiểu nó
không full màn hình tôi sẽ thường ở trọ
này cái này nó sẽ cẩu á nó sẽ cậu ảnh nó
Và thậm chí à Hai màn hình khác nhau Nó
sẽ có cảnh khác nhau như bây giờ giả sử
tôi cứ cho anh
hình ảnh của chồng đi đấy
ờ ờ
con kia nó đang Chiều ra màu xanh này
tức là khi nó đang chạy nhé đấy
Ồ không Ôi cái này phần mềm chứ phần mềm
mới chạy được thẳng trên máy của ông ấy
nước website nào làm website làm gì có
có tác dụng can thiệp được vào mail này
thì và đang chạy nhà thì ông Một ông chị
có cây sồi thôi chứ ông không xuất tinh
được Bây giờ
cứ đợi đợi nó sẽ cho Android ra một cái
gì đó Ở đây tôi thay đổi lại cái màn
hình cho mấy ông không hiểu à
thôi thì thích ai để mình cứ mặc định ở
cửa 20 phút nhắc nhở mình ra nhìn destop
cũng vừa ý hay
ở những nhiên là nên nhìn cách nhìn ra
xa 20m trong vòng 20 giây không ạ thì
mấy ông ngồi văn phòng làm được lấy cho
tôi ngồi nhà ở chẳng có nhìn ra đâu 20
mét là con bé uống để chạy ra xa dấu
ngồi ngắm lại mùi kỹ ngắm kĩ cái màn
hình của ông được nó chị nào chị nó
tôi có tận mấy nghìn chút nhìn đấy
tôi lưu ảnh thử 2018 mà gần đây 15 đổi
đây ít lưu thôi
nhưng mà hội trước thì tôi lưu to còn
Toàn ạ lấy ảnh từ nháy về nên là nó độ
phân giải có
rằng tạm dừng này nhớ ông hoàn toàn thấm
nách backgrounder gì đó
cách nhìn xa chứ cần làm chị em quên
mình gần rồi ông phải học cách nhìn sai
tôi cận rồi Ông vẫn tiếp tục Nhìn gần
thì ông càng tận nghiệm thêm rồi
em heo heo ông có thể cài thêm cái vài
cái để cho nó tránh chung nhé Tôi thấy
cái ảnh với Vĩnh chung không biết rõ
trên của tôi bị chồng hay như nào
Ừ
Ok chưa
Ừ đúng thỏa mãn mấy ông
thỏa mãn sự mong chờ mày lo gì nữa
thứ hai xin lỗi
- 20 phút ông xảy ra thoát ra ngoài màn
hình để ngồi ngắm một lần nó ngoan quá
hợp lý
thế hệ xứng đáng để ngồi đợi giây phút
nào
à
em thấy cái á cái này thì ông cha cái ra
ra không ạ con cái á album của tôi tôi
sẽ chia sẻ sau hoặc thậm chí chỉ chia sẻ
người nào mà
áo gió phần thưởng gì đó sau nhỉ
không nghe Ừ thôi làm việc tiếp đây
à à